good morning Hank it's Tuesday April
14th and today we're going to talk about
a subject close to my heart the world's
largest balls Hank you may not know this
but as it happens I am something of an
expert in the field of the world's
largest balls because the first draft of
my new book Paper Towns was originally
devoted in large part to the world's
largest balls really close readers will
recognize that there's still a small
vestige of the world's largest ball
stuff in Paper Towns but not nearly as
much as I know and today I am going to
tell you everything I know about the
world's largest balls by the way Hank
you'll be surprised to learn that to my
knowledge all of the world's largest
balls are located in the United States
it's almost like Americans are obsessed
with exceptionalism and balls first the
world's largest ball of stamps which is
located in Omaha Nebraska at Boys Town
and yes I've seen it
in fact ain't the world's largest ball
of stamps was the first world's largest
ball I ever saw and I'll never forget my
reaction when I finally got there and
saw it man that's a pretty big ball of
stamps so Hank what happened with the
world's largest ball of stamps is that
the boys at Boys Town just started
taking all the pieces of mail they got
and putting the stamps together into a
ball and eventually they had more than
four million stamps and a gigantic ball
which just goes to show you Hank what
you can accomplish if you're bored and
orphaned Hank the world's largest rubber
band was created by a guy named Joel
Wall who lives in Florida and who I'm
willing to bet is not beloved by his
neighbors it consists of more than
700,000 rubber bands weighing a total of
more than 8,000 pounds and it has a name
of course he named it I mean he spent
years of his life making it it's called
Megaton my name is Megaton I am a rubber
band ball
Hank since I'm sure you're curious I'd
like to read you the Aristotle quote on
Joel's myspace first have a definite
clear practical idea a goal and
objective second have the necessary
means to achieve your ends third adjust
all your means to that end although for
some reason Joel doesn't go on to quote
Aristotle's fourth precept which is of
course fourth don't make that end a
rubber band ball
Hank the world's largest ball of pain is
located in my home state of Indiana in
Alexandria the story of the world's
largest ball of paint begins in 1977
with a guy named Michael Carmichael did
his parents not know what their own last
name was when they named him Michael
so Michael Carmichael
a fun name to say so it's 1977 and
Michael Carmichael is staring at a
baseball and he thinks to himself I
think I'll paint this baseball and then
he kept painting the baseball for thirty
years so that it now has tens of
thousands of coats okay hang just a few
others the world's largest ball of
barbed wire is located in Texas the
world's largest ball of popcorn is in
Sac City Iowa and the world's largest
ball of twine is in Cawker City Kansas
unless you don't consider this shape to
be a ball in which case the world's
largest ball of twine is either in
Branson Missouri Darwin Minnesota or
Wisconsin Hank I don't want to brag but
I've seen all of those balls of twine
and take it from me the one in Darwin
Minnesota is the most impressively ball
like by the way I think it's interesting
how two of the major balls of twine in
America have mailboxes as if you could
send them letters deer ball of twine you
say something interesting about America
but I could never figure out quite what
so I cut you out of my novel best wishes
John so Hank hopefully now you know more
than you used to about the world's
largest balls I'll see you tomorrow